over the last week or so I've been uh
jamming with my friend Michael Rubin and
helping out on this all-in challenge
that I am accepting right now I am
giving away the Ultimate garyvee
Experience how should that go okay you
get to you're gonna be a guest of my
podcast
[Music]
Vayner Nation how are you uh very
special episode
um of the garyvee audio experience this
is one that's been years in the making
as many of you remember during the
beginning of covet I got very passionate
team up with Michael Rubin from Fanatics
to do the all-in challenge you know I
was worried about Vayner and my world
because it was very challenging to
navigate through that first batch of
uh vulnerabilities with clients but I
knew that even if Vayner ran out of
business I'd still be okay and I needed
to do good for a lot of people that were
in trouble and so I'm very honored that
Michael called me and I was a piece of
the group that helped raise 60 million
dollars to feed the hungry during
covid with that campaign during that
campaign I put myself up as one of the
all-in challenges and somebody was going
to win the ultimate Gary experience
and uh and that gentleman is with me
today on this show I'm going to let him
introduce himself tell us about his life
story I'll ask him a bunch of questions
I'll let him ask a couple questions
maybe that might make sense it's
literally for some we're meeting in
person and we're going to work out
together right after this and I gotta
say he's extremely extremely handsome
dude in good shape and so I think he's
gonna crush me in the bench today but
look I don't think we'll film that
Dustin
but anyway he'll say how are you my
friend I'm doing great yeah I'm really
happy to be here I think you're actually
I thought it was just like so fortunate
that you were the person that I haven't
when the event from uh just because my
interests are within business and I was
like you know everybody else like I like
LeBron and I think other celebrities and
stuff were on there because this is so
applicable I'm sure Gary's gonna have
some great lessons that I'll have that I
can take away uh as somebody who aspires
to be an entrepreneur himself um so yeah
I can go into like what yeah tell us
like my you know for a lot of people you
did what everybody else did right it
remind me you could buy like a ticket to
win the raffle right yeah forty five or
ten bucks each yeah like that yeah and
do you remember how many you bought uh
yeah I just bought one one set no way
yeah like one five dollar yeah yeah
really yeah and that was yeah I mean
that just the Vayner Nations thinking
back to when they bought like a thousand
tickets yeah you literally bought one
brother yeah I wasn't gonna go yeah
crazy yeah yeah you bought one five
dollar entry yeah and then yeah I just
left and did you buy like a bunch and
you put them into different things yeah
so I think that I did that that no
[ __ ] because it won't hurt my
feelings do you recall which one you
really wanted the most uh I mean I
remember seeing I think Tom Brady was on
there get out of here that just put a
spear through my soul oh that was
devastating like I totally like I don't
really like the Patriots but I respect
Tom Brady as a guy like I like Tom so
much more now he's a Buccaneer now he's
endearing he's like losing yeah he's a
[ __ ] you're in the NFC I'm like oh I
like Utah I'm like forget about those 20
years of pain
[Music]
um
so yeah okay fine yeah
tell us about your life tell us who you
are as a kid like where'd you grow up
sure yeah I I'm from L.A uh my family
came from Mexico uh when I was a very
young kid so you were born in Mexico
yeah yeah
um but I grew up in L.A though so I
don't really remember much about it I
came when I was three how old are you uh
I was like 10 months older guys I don't
really remember yeah
um but yeah most of my life has been in
La yeah I went to high school there
um worked my ass off and then I was able
to go to Harvard for undergrad
um where I studied English
um and after that I got really
interested in like real estate investing
partly because of all the YouTube
content that I would consume
um and I wanted to you know get in get
into that space yep I think part of it
was also fueled by like my dad I think
every immigrant has this American Dream
store like owning a home yeah Home
Building like a whole owning product
something yeah uh so that got me really
interested in so then I single way back
I apologize we'll go back to this in a
second sure sure that that was a very
quick glance of like I worked my ass off
and went to Harvard yeah Harvard's
pretty legit Dustin
um
when you said you worked your ass off
yeah classroom or because you were first
generation immigrant like correct
classroom and [ __ ] like a job like
yeah Sports because you're in good shape
like bring it back like yeah all of it
huh yeah so it was I think it's hard
because I think I look back to those
days about like what was
the hard-working was luck part of it was
there was some aspect of luck because my
older cousin yeah my little cousin told
me about the magnet school that I should
apply to that had all the available
resources for me to take advantage of uh
but once I had those resources then I
took a bunch of different classes all
the aps when was that
um what grade did you go there I started
that the magnet process I think I was
like I was in seventh grade so it would
have been like 12. so you're going to
public school yeah cousins like hey
there's a smack in school yeah yeah you
and educate me because I'm a little
under educated no yes you had a they had
to accept you or no yeah so basically
all of my neighborhood schools because I
grew up in like South Central L.A yep
it's a pretty bad neighborhood yeah
schools are very underfunded so I knew
from that early age that I was not going
to get a good education there yep
um so and how much was your were your
parents pounding education uh they were
they were very serious about it uh I
think for them not not crazy right no
not not overwhelming yeah because the
reason I'm asking you is like immigrants
just coming over like they have so many
other things they're [ __ ] worried
about as well oh yeah certainly yeah
that like yes it's like education
American Dream yeah but like to go to
Harvard yeah like
did your parent your parents didn't
dream of that or did that they didn't
know what Harvard was
um yeah I knew I figured out what
Harvard was when I was in like 10th
grade um but the reason why they would
push it so much is because first they
wanted us to
um
I think they just wanted us to have a
better job than more than what my
parents before so my dad's a butcher uh
and my dad didn't want to see us go
through that kind of struggle that's
right
um yeah no and then I would say I also
just I've always loved learning mom work
or did she stay at home no my my parents
made that split very early on they
realized that if my mom didn't take care
of us and she wasn't she didn't have
like a watchful eye over us we could get
sucked into the neighborhood which is a
was a reality like you could get into
that like gang life and stuff of course
um and my mom was the one parent said
the same thing yeah I think it's kind of
wrestled but like we didn't you know
Queens wasn't the prettiest place on
Earth where we were at the time but yeah
you know Edison was like like it was
[ __ ] Blue Collar but it wasn't gang
life yeah and like but it was important
for my mom to stay at home and like we
would give up on you know we didn't take
a family vacation for example yeah we
took two yeah same place Disney World
like my whole childhood we gave up we
didn't go out to dinner like we gave up
the luxuries to have that ultimate
luxury yeah
yeah no I completely agree I think
I think it was necessary but but I think
it made us stronger and I not I would I
wouldn't do it any other way if I had it
I think there's a beauty in some of that
um
but anyway so once we how hard was it to
tune out the noise of the neighborhood
during High School
yeah that was that's where it gets that
was when I look at the cliche like story
I have a lot of friends I went to
College in Massachusetts but the
literally the other side of the spectrum
of Harvard I went to Mount Ida college
and most of my friends grew up gang
banging in high school like good kids
that's why they were my friends yeah but
it the high school years was when it was
even like the most challenging it seemed
yeah even for the good they would talk
about kids like you they were bad
students like me they would talk about
their friends
that they were upset about that Jesus
Jail murder yeah [ __ ] all the [ __ ]
you watch on TV in the news of like that
kid was like could have easily gone to
Yale but he [ __ ] got caught up in the
game you know that cliche [ __ ] how did
you were you like what enabled you to
stay on the Harvard cross was it the
school
but even if you're going to the magazine
you're still in the neighborhood no so
magnet schools you actually get bust out
of the neighborhood that I know yeah but
you were still in the neighborhood oh
yeah when I would come back that's right
exactly yeah I would attribute that also
to my dad my dad regardless of how tired
he was he would always drive me to like
events that were outside of the
neighborhood that my school would put on
so my track meets my swimming meets my
when I needed to go take the SCT all
that stuff my dad always was like Hey
I'm not gonna go to work so I can take
you to go do your thing uh so it was
just this is what I'm saying it's like
it is hard work on mine because I was
technically taking the exams and doing
all this other stuff and studying and
all this school come natural to you uh
yes but I also wonder how react
how that really works because I've ever
read George or uh
um Malcolm gladwell's book outliers yep
okay so I haven't read it but I'm very
aware of the thesis yeah so I I think
since I was early like very young my
teachers would always tell me hey you're
a smart kid keep going forward but I
also realized that that part of that was
because
the month that you're born in January
happens to also align to when your brain
is just a little bit bigger than
everybody else's at that age so it means
that you get a lot of like positive
reinforcement and so it's possible that
I was probably you know when you're that
young the little Deltas make a big
difference uh it's possible that I just
got so much positive reinforcement that
I was like hey I'm good at it let me
keep going let me keep going let me keep
going so I don't really was your mom
giving pause is your mom optimistic
person yeah oh yeah definitely she was
she the mother that would say to you
like you can do it you're the best
definitely yeah I think she went further
than that I I remember having a very
strict conversation with her in high
school and I was like hey Mom my school
was getting very intense right now I
can't do my chores I know you're and my
sisters hated me because he was like how
come Jose's not doing his choice
but but my mom was like no you don't
understand like he's not just goofing
around he's literally looking at like
studying she was telling her sister's
like he's a geniusly
not no but he would say like he's
studying all day long like if you if you
would do that I would do the exact same
thing for you
um so you're of of three so we're four I
have three younger sisters I love it
you're the oldest brother of time yeah
that's cool yeah yeah I love them do you
love that sense of responsibility yeah I
think it made me mature faster but but
also now like
I don't know I think they're my closest
friends they're the people that I can
trust
fully and that's hard to find how old
are you I'm 25. and them uh so one of my
so one is 24 the other one is 19 and the
other is 18. so one just started college
yeah that's awesome yeah she's having a
good time but you were the outlier
academically yeah yeah I don't know
where that part came from I think part
of it is just I I needed a school that
would pay for my entire education of
course and Harvard was one of those
places uh so I was like okay did you
[ __ ] when you got in
I was in public so no but I was I was it
was honestly like a life-changing moment
I was like this is this feels it I felt
the trajectory of my life just
completely I just felt it yeah you just
feel it you know that life is different
now where else did you get accepted to
uh so I applied earlier to Harvard
because and that was it and then I was
like I'm done of course I studied so
hard I was like I'm good and did like
your friends make fun of you like like
Razz you like oh Harvard boy oh
definitely yeah yeah oh yeah definitely
um but I don't know I think all of that
just comes from like a sense of like you
know yeah and so now you're out of it
like give me the yeah give me the
postmortem on the 25 year old from the
streets yeah who went through Harvard
for four years what do you what do you
think I would say
um
I think Harvard's difficult the first
time you go around it there Harvard's a
lot easier when you're
the second generation in and there are
people at Harvard who are like 10
generations of course of course um but I
think the first time it's difficult
because
first there are some cultural aspects
that you're not really that I wasn't
aware of like I didn't even know what
squash was I didn't know what rowing was
of course I didn't know what all of
these cultural icon things that people
connect with uh all those bougie Sports
yeah so that was difficult for me when I
first started
um
later on as you go through your first
year you create enough shared
experiences that it becomes a lot easier
to become you can make friends and stuff
makes sense but early on I remember that
was a big obstacle I think that first
month was [ __ ] wrong I would say the
first like six months was was tough
first year yeah yeah because I was I was
even weather right weather's different
yeah that Boston [ __ ] weather I also
was very used to going that same as New
York but I just hate the Patriots so
much go ahead I also was just used to
always coming back home to like with my
parents my mom and dad and we didn't
live like we don't live in a very very
big place in L.A and I know it's like it
kind of sucks but it's also really nice
to have noise in the house yeah yeah
whereas if you just go home by yourself
the lights are off you turn them on it's
kind of I don't know so the first
shooter was lonely first year was tough
yeah and how about academically yeah no
academically was fun I think my school
prepared me enough you had the academics
that was fine the social part was just
like it was just weird for me yeah it
was tough uh just because we didn't have
the shared experiences I know yeah and
you didn't get the luck of the draw of
like another kind of non-shared
experience you didn't get that cliche in
a movie yeah another kid from the other
side of tracks and you guys became
homies it didn't that didn't like play
out no okay and then there's also I I
think Harvard tried to connect People
based off of culture they were like hey
this is a Hispanic kid let's put him
with other Hispanic kids I think that's
I like the where that comes from it came
from good intent yes but it's not
sometimes as practical as one would
think it's difficult because
so I would notice that a lot of the
Hispanic kids from like Harvard and
these other schools are generally
International kids that's right and
those are rich kids no no they share a
lot more in common with kids from here
yeah uh so that was like I understand
where it was coming from but it doesn't
really work out that way I actually
would find what was what would you like
no I'm sorry I want to hear that yeah I
actually find I would find more
similarities with like the poor kid from
Indiana or like of course you know we
would because we knew the same stuff
yeah of course yeah I actually was going
to that's where I was going well if you
had to like recap it right now what was
the Breakthrough socially for you yeah
in Harvard uh I would say I started
playing Futsal like indoor soccer and
then I met one of my good friends who
I'm actually gonna go visit we get
together all the time and then he
introduced me to the rest of his friends
so that was it that's the poor first new
first it's just [ __ ] out of like it's
the same old story yeah so is that one
kid and his friend group and that became
your Social Circle exactly and then from
then on the three years after that I had
a had a blast yeah it was great that's
awesome yeah but yeah I would I would do
it all over again as a 25 year old yeah
telling that story Mrs compelling
what can you tell and knowing my
audience what can you tell
the parent that's listening right now
who has the 13 year old they're more
like me
Scrapper first generation made it and
their child is actually not entrepreneur
academic Superstar
um what Insight can you give to somebody
who's listening right now who's a 10 to
13 year old that's going down that path
and maybe it wasn't their path so they
don't have insights since you freshly
are off that path any hot take that you
can say like hey parents always remember
this or consider this or watch out for
this yeah I'm actually a big fan of
people who say that college isn't for
everybody because I I completely agree I
think the world endows or whatever you
happen to believe in luck whatever
um
I think you're given a set of talents
and people should harness those talents
and you should lean into them so there's
some people who are very talented in
academics cool lean into those but
there's some people who that's not their
strength people are very creative or
people are very funny lean into those
strengths so that's what I would say
don't lose hope on your kid because of
that like lit like actually take the
time to listen to what the kid is good
at you know what's fun is that it's it's
for me it comes natural if my kid was a
comedian to like you're the next Kevin
Hart if you know if they're you know
it's actually the thing that is
worrisome for me is I get a lot of
emails and DMS from parents like yo
garyvee what do I do like I'm like you
bro and this my [ __ ] kid's getting
straight A's I'm like awesome I'm like
don't let them become anxious about the
grades yeah you know like yeah that's
one thing yeah make sure they're happy
yeah but like like
you know lean into the truth yeah to a
parent's ideology we speak a lot about
the paranaliology of like you got to be
a good student you're not you're [ __ ]
up that your kid's an entrepreneur for a
lot of us entrepreneurs it's the reverse
yeah
yeah what um what are so let's pick back
up the story real estate caught your
attention so like where are you at at
this point in your career yeah so I went
back to LA I was working for a real
estate PE firm um and I was investing in
multi-family and industrial buildings
yep
um I had a great time learning that but
I also wanted to figure out like I knew
I wanted to start my own business I
don't really
want to work underneath anybody
um and I just like that ownership that
you take and that risk taking so I
applied for business school during the
pandemic I don't know if I had won the
prize yet but I got into the Stanford's
Graduate School of Business uh and so
now I'm completing my second year there
wow and I'm about to graduate uh
hopefully I'm working on a startup with
a friend of mine from civil engineering
school we'll see how that one goes uh
anything you can cheer on that front yet
yeah yeah so the hypothesis so basically
we are well he he's the brains he's the
PHD in civil engineering he created a
model that will give you suggestions on
how to make structural and
non-structural improvements to buildings
to make them more resistant against
hurricanes earthquakes buildings that
are standing now both so you can make oh
even pre-conscious yeah so even
reconstruction uh when it's
pre-construction you can make even
better improvements like non-structural
improvements
um roll still exactly post is [ __ ]
challenging it's more difficult yeah
yeah exactly and then the ROI debate and
all those things for all of that yeah
yeah so right now we're doing Stanford
has this class called Lean LaunchPad and
so we're conducting a bunch of
interviews with industry professionals
that I know
um and to ask them like which customer
who would you think would be the ideal
customer for this yep uh and so I think
the final product exactly exactly yeah
so I think what we're imagining is
creating some sort of SAS tool where we
create a nice front end yep have the
user put in their the database of the
building charged them monthly yeah get
value did it something like that I love
that um before we get out of here
anything you want to ask me
yeah uh I would I mean I I actually have
a few questions let's do it try to make
this valuable for the listeners okay
that's fun we should just do random
random oh okay
around every other person right like we
have all these like fancy [ __ ] on the
show like yeah like this is more of a
journey like that was cool yeah I like
liked it more yeah
yeah nice thanks Dustin so I guess the
question that I was gonna ask everybody
we love dust we gotta change this trend
I started that I don't even like
um when you started like vaynerx yes
um what was the initial business idea
and what were some key moments as you
were starting your company the what
happened was
speak we see what you're doing on this
on the Twitter this is how people talk
back yeah and I was like okay that's so
cool and they're like they're like
you know what's your fee and I was like
fee
you know and and I was like and I like
really was just like so excited to go to
ESPN and talk to them I was like well
what do you guys normally and they're
like well you know would you do five
thousand dollars for the hour
and that seemed like a trillion dollars
because you understand at this point in
my career I was still I built a huge
business for my dad but I wasn't making
a lot of money yeah and so like and
listen 90 000 a year is a lot of money
but like not compared to what I was
doing and I was 34 and I've been doing
it for 12 years so like this was like
big to me and I
remember I went and not only did was it
cool to get five thousand bucks I loved
it I talked for an hour about big
business it wasn't wine I'd been doing
that for 20 years of my life and I was
and it was just very obvious to me that
and I remember thinking like wait a
minute I'm not that I thought that I was
smarter but I definitely felt like these
are like big corporate heads at ESPN and
I'm like wait a minute you know just
kind of all rushed in my head of like
there's something here got out of the
office in Midtown New York and called AJ
my brother he was at bu not far from
where you were and uh and I was like bro
because we knew we wanted to start a
business together and this must have
been like the fall so this was probably
the beginning of his senior year in May
we had a bullseye that we were going to
start a business when he got out of
school because he already knew he didn't
want to go into the wine business the
liquor business and so it was we were
starting we were doing things we did
this like t-shirt search engine please
dress me and like doing all these fun
things we probably thought we were going
to do fantasy sports okay
which probably would have been right by
the way because we were ahead of that
trend
but I said hey
you know you know this is that skill I
have you like marketing social media all
this stuff I'm like why don't we just
start a consultancy that's when I called
it at first not in an agency and we'll
get paid to learn
and let's see what happens so the thesis
was get paid to learn and figure it out
yeah two years later so I was still
running the wine business I just wrote
crush it the book right there on the
Shelf yeah that uh this one right there
you see it oh this one yes and that was
my first book which was basically like
hey social media's gonna be a big deal
yeah right look look even what you said
cash in on your passion right like like
the internet will make the the [ __ ]
that people thought the hyperbole of
like follow your dreams now practical
unlike it was ever before the internet
yeah that was the hypothesis the book
went banana spiral New York Times
bestseller went bananas now I'm speaking
garyvee is being built
now my wine company I'm still running my
dad's business and now me and my brother
have this company
in August of 2011 which was two years
two months after three three months
after we started it I kind of just like
had this moment where it was not
sustainable anymore and I was like I
gotta decide I was like a third a third
a third and I was like I want to do one
thing ninety percent and five percent
the other things and I decided to go all
in on vaynermedia with a new hypothesis
which was I'm gonna build the greatest
marketing company of all time yeah as an
operating system to my private Equity
Behavior so instead of doing what PE
does what you know which is by companies
where they see opportunity of better
management and better margin I'm going
to buy companies where I see the
opportunity to create hyper growth
against intellectual property okay could
you impact that a little bit sure I'm
gonna buy one day I'm gonna buy The
Smurfs IP okay one day I'm gonna buy
Captain Crunch from PepsiCo one day I'm
gonna buy Bubblicious from Mondelez take
it out
and then make everybody on Tick Tock
chew Bubblicious and quadruple growth
okay because that's my skill yeah
so that was 2011.
fast forward to 2021 after 10 years of
building a massive company
this nft thing comes along and I go
huh
maybe I don't need to buy the
intellectual property maybe I can
establish the intellectual property yeah
and that's how be friends was born along
the way I started empathy wines
with people that worked here sold out
the consolation for a substantial exit I
started resi the restaurant app
here oh no way back to Amex I didn't
know that's cool now v-friend so it's
working this is the operating system
yeah for all my other Behavior
and um and so I think I have a moat that
most people don't have which is you know
this
true private Equity like being smart
financially and operationally is
commoditized there are tens of thousands
of people on Earth that know what to do
hey Chuck E Cheese's not been run well
let's uh we'll take a former person a
partner you know what it is yeah yeah
the amount of people on Earth that know
how to leverage media and creative on
CTV Tick Tock influencer like the true
craft of what I do for a living is very
few and the ones that are they're Mr
Beast they're like building their own
trillion dollar stuff so
I'm uh I'm in a nice spot in my career
I'm young I turn 47 in a couple weeks
and
I've got 40 years of being on the field
in my opinion yeah because I'm kind of
one of these I think I'll do it until
the end so I'd like to think I live to
100 Maybe by 87 I'll be like all right
yeah maybe I'll take some foot off the
pedal but there's no foot off the pedal
from who I am right now for at least 30.
yeah and so 30 years of
execution on the back of now where I'm
at is going to lead to a whole lot of
[ __ ] that I probably can't even dream of
and a lot of [ __ ] that I am dreaming of
and so
um that was the hypothesis of Vayner it
was two get paid to learn it was the
recession it was like [ __ ] this is the
most practical thing
quickly behind that build the greatest
marketing company in the world as an
operating system to affect the other 40
meaningful businesses I built wow that's
amazing
um I guess just as a follow-up what are
some interesting Trends you're seeing
now on social media
uh The Tick Tock application of
everything so now the algorithm is
rewarding the content
from an organic standpoint that we
didn't see for the last decade so six
years ago hey Gary I want to build
social media to build up my business
great start putting out tons of content
to get followers so that you have a big
enough base of followers that when you
post a good amount of people see it
now it's make great content for the
platform and the psychology of who
you're trying to make it for and watch
the algorithm put it in front of tons
and tons of people on the Merit of the
creative
that's a game changer
AKA in plain English if you want to
start a coffee shop in Boston tomorrow
yeah your first post on Tick Tock could
get a million views and build your
business for you overnight that was
unheard of
the last time this happened was Facebook
fan pages in 2011 which is why Facebook
became Facebook it was always about
rewarding creators with more awareness
based on their creativity not on their
ad spend or ability to build a following
that was like the lightning in the
bottle that would get people addicted
that's what I loved about Twitter I'll
never forget when Twitter when I
understood that Twitter had a retweet
like this is day one Twitter I'm like
wait a minute so you post but wait a
minute somebody likes it they retweet it
and retweet wasn't there it was people
doing it I was on Twitter before the
retweet button people would see a tweet
control copy it oh wow put RT colon and
paste it it's so much work
um so you know like these are the trends
that I've always thought about Word of
Mouth awareness sorry about that you
know and so stuff like that and so
um you know I think um the biggest trend
is the tick tockification of social
awesome okay
um yeah let me know when if
when we have to go yeah well you know
what you know what I just didn't realize
Mike's in my Lobby Mike flew in to work
us out oh no I forgot awesome so pumped
all right listen I think that's good
yeah I think we got to go work out yes I
think this was very real this was good
everybody was listening I actually need
your help you know I read Twitter the
most can everybody just tweet let's use
the hashtag Jose uh Jose
GB
j-o-s-e-gb use that hashtag
I think it's specific enough I don't
think it's not a Jose GB hashtags I'll
find them it's all I know the day this
is going to launch so I'll watch for the
first week
um leave your feedback because I feel
like me and Dustin sensed that this was
a different kind of podcast I feel
different and so I'm actually curious
what you all felt because that feedback
may give me an insight to maybe starting
a series or shifting my podcast or
making new content
thank you my young friend thank you for
making such a good show thank you for
having me I'm super excited let's go
pump some [ __ ] iron let's do it
[Music]